well hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to don't whack
your boss or actually this is not the
original game whack your boss this is
actually a completely different game but
now with superpowers so you get to kill
your boss in horror pulling new ways and
I'm sure that's gonna be the oh hello hi
sir how are you doing I'll get that
deadline done just as soon as I find
what the hell is this hello this
Wolverine claws oh they are how did you
just put them in your hands okay oh my
god oh god I don't know why but I think
it's like an evolution of like
tryptophan stop that oh god it's like a
different version a trip to phobia
that's so I hate it like when in the
first Resident Evil movie you know in
the beginning when they're in the laser
trap I get oh man get away how do I stop
it
next oh god ah I'm not okay with that
alright I mean is this just an a sad
person that lives alone in with all
these super bra all Hulk fists yes
please I don't know how putting these on
and also what off
oh there we go there's the reference I
was looking for oh that was adorable
yeah I know about wacky teacher this
one's marginally well actually neither
acceptable never murder your superiors
in any fad don't kill anybody how about
we just go with that one this is a video
game and here we can relieve stress
without worrying too much
instead of flute do I need it are we are
we summoning Godzilla I said I seem to
recall something like this we're gonna
go on an adventure I'm gonna name you
chica okay go have fun rampaging through
the city a best way to take out all the
stress hello
I don't even know what that is is that a
pocket protector oh it was pocket what's
supposed to be I'm not entirely sure
don't know
see that might be a reference to a
videogames and I'm not entirely sure
what it is but I'll stop it with the
Wolverine Oh God that one's Turk Schmitt
everything about me yeah but I was right
about that being a pocket now am I gonna
become Superman here I'm guessing that's
either gonna be to do with heat vision
or cold breath and maybe a combination
of the two oh man yeah oh no oh no I
just remembered the injustice guy okay
this is we're gonna do this you know you
know if you were going up at the same
speed it would have been a fireball on
the way up - oh well then that's nice
you just have that Cape lying around the
power to destroy the entire planet just
in the palm of your hand and you take it
out on your boss and all of your
unfortunate neighborhoods everyone else
in the office oh hello I mean you're
Ramiro get to you in a second
got a Rubik's Cube oh no don't be
another slicey one Oh same thing in the
cute
oh no it's the Transformers thingy all
of your coworkers this oh man oh man I
know who this statue is I can't remember
he's like the precursor to the Power
Rangers or something like that well so
we got is that an ro shootin our Naruto
headband never watched Naruto this could
be kinky I have a feeling it's not gonna
be I'm such an old man is all I think
about wow he's is very dead stop it with
the Wolverine I'm not okay with that
seven and thirty alright mule mill come
on mule near there okay now wasting time
around that one same like for it just
doesn't give a crap by a battery okay
here we go
whatever the hell this is another flute
type thingy Oh nope light saber not
exactly a superpower unless you have the
force well Wow now I'm scared even
though the wound would have been
cauterized and there's the super power
something tells me that light saber
should have been red oh did you die did
you become one with the force happen you
just called away cuz the force didn't
want to be imbalanced anymore by your
goal that spideyman
a web globe oh yeah it is I've been
gooped oh I've got so much go [ __ ] oh
my the Google oh wow
something tells me Spidey wouldn't have
done that I just want to say that
outright but he would have been very
nice to his opponents but he probably
wouldn't kill him saying just super
saiyan if there's the same one over here
who is this oh that's that's scorpion
probably or Sub Zero depending on which
one oh very cool
get it ha ha very cool okay
only two more and I don't know where the
hell they're gonna be oh oh there's the
Super Saiyan one yes do it
summon Shenron
so much unnecessary - there's so many
casualties of this okay goodbye Goku
have a good one
you be nice now oh my gosh I don't know
why I'm quick I don't know why I'm still
questioning the logic of these games
because of course it's tips
ridiculousness but I mean come on what
do this Sponge Bob up there surprise
he's not a superpower oh here we go
oh is that Cyclops are we gonna laser
him to death oh that would be scared -
even though you just murdered him and he
probably shouldn't be Wow there was a
door there was literally a door right
over there why couldn't you oh I guess
we're done then okay so let's whack your
boss with superpowers that was a fun
adventure in demoniacal it's an insanity
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to check out the
other whacking games there's a link in
the description below and if you want to
play this for yourself for whatever
stress-relieving reasons there's another
link in the description as well thank
you so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
the trick is you gotta let go on those
and actually fall down oh wow I jumped